hey the boys season 2 has a trailer it's
been a while since I've talked about a
trailer I think I maybe not it's all
kind of a blur or maybe it dreams
what is the boys season 2 as a teaser
trailer and I'm gonna talk about it why
because in the bus fire of 2020 there
are two things I really look forward to
the boys season 2 and Cobra Kai write
the teaser trailer for the boys season 2
so butcher and his crew they're very
wanted we're talking about they have
their own little segment on not Crime
Stoppers they're all kind of worried but
butchers he's being butcher about it
daddy's home or as I like to call it
Pokeno audition tape because I'm just
saying Karl Urban and the boys this
reminds me of Kane oh I wouldn't hate it
if he was Cana I feel like I've already
said that in a video probably my video
on the boys season one it's a blur maybe
a dream but apparently he got out of
that situation we left him in the boys
season one we also see home Lander push
a kid off a roof which I imagine is and
welcome to the only spoiler warning you
get for the boys season one okay you're
still here
you don't care moving on his kid from
the end of the boys season wine I mean
but his eyes were all glowy is he
invincible is the kid gonna splat it's
like well I could shoot lasers out of my
eyes but I'm not impervious to gravity
and the sudden stop at the end don't
know but this teaser trailer for the boy
season 2 it has what I wanted which is
the energy it has the energy of the boys
while showing you a lot of violence that
I probably shouldn't show here because
monetization is very important to a
YouTube channel proper the sake of
entertainment there you go heads popping
head severed as for that I'm no
scientist but I have it on good
authority that that will keep you very
warm on the planet Hoth and that's your
lesson on thermodynamics although I will
say you know what would have actually
worked well with this trailer if they
had a song from the [ __ ] Spice
Girls just saying good throwback anyhow
okay I understand maybe in the next trip
a guy can hope what can I say but we
also see some new heroes or heroes color
heroes most of them are [ __ ] bag point
is we have storm from x-men coming onto
the scene or elf from season to
appearance which was not good but in the
defense of heroes season 2 it was cut
short because of a writer's strike at
the time the second half of season 2
would have dealt with a pandemic I think
it's safe to say
second half of Hero season two well it's
[ __ ] also but I'm digging this trailer
for the boys Susan - it had the attitude
it had the violence I'm looking forward
to it because the boys was just that
surprised Susan series alert all right
ago so Wow
when I got done watching and I had a
friend visit shortly after and I was
like you have to watch this I watched it
again so that's it I figured I talk
about the teaser trailer for the boys
season - why well first of all because I
wanted to second of all because I went
to bed at 9:00 p.m. that seemed a
responsible thing to do then I woke up
at 2:00 a.m. and I was just up couldn't
go back to sleep so now I'm gonna ramble
about the boys season 2 trailer because
looks good though looks wholesome but I
said the trailer to the boys season -
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see moe
[Music]